[موسيقى]
القانون يتضمن ثلاث نقاط اساسيه النقطه
الاولى عدم قبول اي لا شيء يصل الى
الاراضي البريطانيه عن طريق غير شرعي رقم
اثنين
القانون ينص على ان الدخول الى البريطانيا
من اجل الحصول على اللجوء لا بد ان يتقدم
الى السلطات البريطانيه في اماكن تواجده
ويقدم لجوء في تلك المنطقه رقم ثلاثه ان
يتم وصول اللاجئين عبر الكوتا الدوليه او
الكوتا التي تحددها المفوضيه المفوضيه
العليا للاجئين
[موسيقى]
نهايه الامم المتحده اعترضت على هذا
القانون ولا ننسى ايضا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومؤسساته ووكالاته تعترض على هذا
القانون وخاصه القانون الانساني الاوروبي
الذي تم الاتفاق عليه منذ اربعه او خمسه
سنوات تقريبا وتم التوقيع عليه قانونا كما
ذكرنا من الناحيه السياده كدوله ممكن
استخدامها لكن من الناحيه المنظومه
القانون منظومه القانونيه للقانون الدولي
الانساني وحقوق الانسان هذا يعتبر منافي
[موسيقى]
قواعد الاساسيه لحقوق الانسان ولا ننسى
ايضا ان هناك عده مجالات في الاعتراض على
هذا القانون سواء المحاكم البريطانيه سواء
محكمه العدل الاوروبيه سواء المحاكم بشكل
عام لانه قانون يتعارض مع ميثاق حقوق
الانسان وايضا مع بعض بنود القانون الدولي
الان ساني
هي القضيه بدات في الخلاف الشديد الذي حصل
بين فرنسا
وبريطانيا على عبور المهاجرين عبر بحر
الماوس
اللي كانوا يتجمعوا في فرنسا ثم ينتقلوا
الى بريطانيا بشكل
عن طريق الماوس اما عن طريق القوارب او
الشاحنات او قطارات الحقيقه ادى هذا العمل
الى ازمه دبلوماسيه بين البريطانيين وبين
الفرنسيين على اسره برئاسه الوزراء اراده
ان تخرج قانون استغل رئيس الوزراء الجديد
ووزيره الهجره وزيره الداخليه
البريطانيين
هذه الازمه الكبيره وارادوا ان يمرروا
قانون
عمليه نقل المهاجرين الى رواندا او الى
دوله اخرى هو عمليه معقده جدا حتى في
القانون البريطاني عمليه معقده جدا وحسب
الاحصائيات الحقوقيه القانونيه تتحدث ان
حتى لو اراد رئيس الوزراء ان يقوم او
وزيره الهجره ان تقوم بهذا القانون هناك
لن يستطيعوا ان يرسلوا اكثر من 200 لاجئ
لا ننسى ان بريطانيا استقبلت فقط هذا
العام اكثر من 45 الف
وزياده عن من المهاجرين
[موسيقى]